google has agreed to pay a record 170
million dollar fine for violating
children's privacy regular to say
YouTube which is owned by Google
illegally collected personal information
about users under the age of 13 without
parental consent
the tech giant then used that data to
target advertising the settlement is the
largest in a children's privacy case in
the United States in addition to the
fine google says it will make changes to
its privacy rules on YouTube in a free -
is the chief technology correspondent at
the news website Axios and says there
are too many loopholes in YouTube's
current system which allows information
gathering on children basically what
we're talking about here is programming
that's clearly designed for children but
isn't labeled as kids content and
therefore has targeted advertising and
YouTube saying they're gonna take two
big steps to try and addresses one
they're gonna insist but you know we'll
see how strict they are that content
creators label content that's intended
for children and then also that they're
gonna use their own machine learning and
artificial intelligence to try and
decide and surface and notice what is
children's content and then you know
take action to not serve targeted
advertising against that type of content
and the issue right now is that there's
tons of kids on the main YouTube site
there's a separate site called YouTube
kids but that's not where most kids
content is watched US authorities just
don't have the ability to find these
tech companies any amounts that really
make a difference I mean obviously 170
million dollars isn't nothing but it's
not very much to Google and it certainly
is a drop in the bucket to the amount of
revenue that YouTube is bringing in we
see much more significant fines when
Europe takes action but even still the
fines themselves tend not to be the
deterrent that one would want so really
what you have to look at are the changes
to their business contact to see if this
is gonna make any sort of difference